All right, you're done.
Let's take a look at the solution.
While we cannot insert
a vector directly,
we can easily convert
a vector to an array.
Once we've done this, the BulkInsert
method will insert very efficiently.
As you can see, we've uncommented
out these next series of lines.
This allows us to test our output,
to make sure
that we've actually inserted
the right thing into the database.
Let's actually run our app.
And, as you can see, we're actually
reading the data out of the database
that we just inserted all correctly.
Now, our backend will
update efficiently, but we
really need a way to update the frontend
without doing it on the main UI thread.
Now, our backend will update
efficiently, but we really need to be
querying things before requesting
them from the internet.
After all, the point is to
have a responsive application.
We're still not even updating
the screen until after we've
pulled data down from the web.
We also want to avoid doing
our query on the UI thread.
Because, doing operations like queries
on the UI thread cause Android not to be
able to draw frames fast enough,
which introduces frame rate jitter.
Fortunately, Android offers
a pattern for that known as loaders.